so the view of the national incident
management team is
at twofold firstly that it would be
premature to move glasgow out of level
three immediately
this week while the situation remains so
fragile
however and secondly if incidence
continues to stabilize
and assuming levels of hospitalization
remain
reasonably stable the incident
management team
has made uh clear to me that they would
support a move to level two
from the end of next week so this time
next week
of course it's necessary that we do see
progress continue
we will be watching the critical
statistics carefully
every day but if the massive public
health efforts continue to have an
impact
if our collective efforts to drive the
virus back
continue then from next saturday
friday into saturday the fifth of june
the plan would be for the city to move
to level two but i want to be clear here
again just in the interest as i've
always tried to be
to be frank with everybody we do need to
see these positive signs continue
uh to make that a reality so to give as
much advanced notice as possible because
i know
the lack of notice is one of the
frustrations for people and
for businesses in particular i intend to
confirm any decision
no later than wednesday of next week
my message to the people of glasgow is
don't lose heart
on the contrary at take part from the
progress that we are seeing
um i live in glasgow so i know how hard
this is from my own personal life but
please
continue to help with all of the public
health efforts that are in place because
if we continue to do this
then we will make that move from level
three down to level two and then after
that hopefully get back on track
uh down the levels uh further